[Music]
my name is kevin harrison and i'm the
owner and operator of project laser
which is a mobile laser cleaning service
in western australia
[Music]
lasers are really good at cleaning soot
off basically any hard substrate so that
can be a wooden beam a steel beam a
painted wall paving stones bricks
all sorts of surfaces whether it's
really smooth or porous we're sending
thousands of light pulses every second
into the surface contamination this is
getting absorbed into the soot and it's
basically vaporizing it or popping off
the surface
on this day we were called in to help
out remove smoke damage from a home that
had a molotov cocktail thrown into it
there was smoke filled throughout the
home on both stories like really really
dark black soot we had to remove smoke
damage from every single surface so this
was within the kitchen lounges bathrooms
we used a large laser for this job
because it's got the 15 meter hose we
parked the vehicle right next to the
house and then just extended the fiber
optic cable through a door that had been
kicked in and that gave us access to the
majority of the house this was a really
long process basically worked from left
to right
once we finished laser cleaning we did
wipe down the walls just to ensure that
there's no vagrant soot on the surface
we use a pulse laser which is basically
a tool to remove thin layers of surface
contamination it's the benefits of a
pulse laser it has no abrasive power so
no matter how hard we try we can't
profile scratch or damage a surface
porous brick is going to absorb more of
the soot it's got all the cracks and
crevices where soot will sit and you may
have to clean at certain different
angles whereas if you've got a nice
smooth painted surface it's all even
there's no soot hiding in different
cracks and crevices here we're doing
smoke damage removal with our small 200
watt mobile laser on a rammed earth wall
you'd run your fingers over the wall it
was all crumbly and falling apart so if
they'd chosen to use high pressure water
chemicals and scrubbing brushes they
would have removed lots of material
this was a bush fire that basically came
up to the home and licked the wall and
then caught the trusses on fire so there
was also some smoke damage cleaning
inside the house that we had to carry
out
when you're using a laser cleaning
machine you need to take safety very
seriously it is very easy to mitigate
the risks firstly that can be done by
wearing the correct safety glasses so
for us that's wearing safety glasses
that protect your eyes from the 1064
infrared laser pulses secondly we've
spent an uncomfortable amount of money
on respirators so everyone who operates
the laser will be wearing a respirator
the beautiful thing about using a laser
cleaning machine is you can really
adjust the parameters depending on what
you're cleaning
if you want to clean a larger area
quicker you can have a beam that goes
for example 100 millimeters wide or
about three and a half inches if you
wanted to doing large areas you could
turn the power up and have a large beam
and at the same time you could really
wind the power down if you wanted to
remove soot off a chandelier or a
bathtub or the side of a tv you really
could wind it down enough to not damage
even plastics if necessary
with our smaller laser it's got a really
defined focal zones an inch or a couple
centimeters so if you're not with
perfectly within that focal zone the
laser is not going to be effectively
cleaning the beauty of the laser is you
can just move backwards and forwards
slowly and you'll hear when the laser is
at its loudest which is basically when
it's chewing through the you could laser
clean with your eyes closed and just use
your ears once you get used to the sound
on this job we're using our 500 watt
laser cleaning machine to remove smoke
damage from a pool pump that caught on
fire once we arrived on site we saw that
we could easily put our fiber optic
cable over the fence unfortunately there
was a lot of heat with this fire so
there was a bit of area where the bricks
were permanently oxidized so there was a
fair few spots where there's actually
permanent damage on the bricks we took
off all the old plug points screws that
were still stuck in the wall this just
enabled us to really clean the whole
wall properly if we need to protect any
hoses or cables when we're laser
cleaning put blue masking tape over the
surface or ideally you put aluminium
foil tape aluminium reflects up to 95 of
infrared light so it's really easy to to
stop the laser pulses
the laser cleaning is very different to
traditional cleaning methods for
removing soot externally they would use
high pressure water internally on
painted surfaces you're generally using
a degreaser a bleach countless rags
chemical gloves be spraying the chemical
onto the surface you're wiping it off
and then you'd be using more clean rags
just until that surface was clean enough
that they could apply another paint over
the top lasers are basically a single
pass there's no water there's no
chemicals getting used it's definitely
the cleanest process both internally and
externally
laser cleaning is a brilliant technology
it's really only getting started in the
sense of being mobile so the technology
is really growing rapidly every city in
the world is in the next few years
they're going to have a laser cleaning
company that specifically targets smoke
damage it's a good feeling to be one of
the first companies doing it and doing
it well
you